sur le profil de l'homme interpellé ce
que l'on sait c'est qu'il va avoir 24
ans à la fin de l'année il est né en
algérie il est très défavorablement
connu à la fois des services de police
et de justice avec nous dit on une
vingtaine de mentions à son casier
judiciaire des faits de droits communs
trafic de stupéfiants détention de
stupéfiants multiples vols extorsion
ainsi que violences et un jeune qui
errent entre plusieurs communes du val
d'oise et la capitale différentes
adresses où il a des connaissances il
avait d'ailleurs sollicité certains de
ses amis pour les bergers à la nuit
dernière car normalement il dort à
lattes à l'hôtel notamment ici à cergy
pontoise
merci dioro d'être avec no mercy
beaucoup sur ses revenus on voulait
absolument vous à voir ce soir on a été
très très très très choqué par ce que
vous avez subi la première question
qu'on a tous envie de vous poser les
téléspectateurs en premier c'est quand
vous allez déjà vraiment mal tous demain
donc je suis très mal que malte vraiment
c'est moralement quoi exactement est
physiquement aux invités on a vu la
violence des coups on a vu la violence
verbale
je vous dis je vous ai vu diogo vous
étiez même vous j'ai l'impression que
vous compreniez pas en fait vous étiez
lui perdu abasourdi perdu devant ce qui
s'est passé vous dit comment un individu
peut avoir un tel comportement
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que j'avais été
chez vous invite à l'hôpital vous avez
porté plainte est ce que vous êtes
soulagé aujourd'hui de savoir que cet
individu a été arrêté ou c'est plus
profond que ça vous dit aujourd'hui ce
que j'ai vécu
j'aimerais pas que ça arrive à d'autres
personnes et aujourd'hui ce que j'ai
vécu c'est ça reflète un mal bien plus
profond dans la société dans laquelle on
vit aujourd'hui
donc voilà parce que je suis vraiment
soulagé parce que l'humain lui quelques
appels par la police donc ça va ce large
était donc je vais passer un message aux
livres à huit vous livrer des vidéos
donc c'est vraiment c'est vrai travail
pas c'est sûr c'est pas travailler
facilement des documents je sais vous à
ne pas vous n'êtes pas protégé ça c'est
un travail qui est très compliqué il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'agressions je vous
dis vous faites un travail
en plus les gens sont extrêmement sont
pas sympas alonso voit ils sont ils sont
méprisants c'est vrai que c'est c'est
pas évident mais là ça a été
c'était bien au delà de la méprise oui
vous avez vous êtes choquer aujourd'hui
toujours choquée tout chaud vous avez
peur aujourd'hui oui oui j'ai toujours
peur les mots qu'il a eu envers vous et
les insultes racistes qu'on a tous vu
ici elles ont été terribles parce que
c'est ça aussi ça vous a vraiment marqué
moralement
oui c'est vraiment c'est quelqu'un que
vous connaissez ou pas je ne méconnais
pas dedans que moi je suis arrivé parce
que ça sonnait parce que ces plateformes
on est que ça soit bon qu'on soit sûr et
voiture refuse donc je réponds après
suis allé chercher la commande c'est la
première fois que vous allez dans ce
restaurant sur scène qu'on n'a pas pris
les points font souvent bon plus que
trois ou quatre fois
d'accord ça se passait toujours bien
dans ce restaurant où exactement je suis
retrait donc je prends la commande après
je parle donc quand je suis arrivé donc
moi je mets toujours la musique pour
donc pas ce qu'il faut faire la route
était une religion charmant donc on
apprend donc là le vent recevront donc
j'ai pris la commande en sortant donc le
mec qui se pressait devant moi pour dire
que été arrêté votre sens de votre
musique
donc il dit non je peux pas donc pas
politesse gd sans le son navire mais je
crois le mec qui était d'y croire soit
il habite dans le quartier de condesa
les soirs par politesse
le mec il vécu j'étais exactement le
sens mais ils n'ont pas pris c'est
posséder au moins deux coups pour
maximiser donc après le saut a été très
calme
après je vous en dévoiler pour que j'ai
pas de lui à savoir que j'ai pas peur
donc parce que le matin c'est pendant la
bagarre ça ne compte pas donc voilà je
suis pas là pour la violence tiens ça
vous vous avez vous avez pas pensé un
instant qu'il allait donner la main sur
vous dans une fois que la minute que je
vous parle donc de doc gso et je suis
sonné je trouvais pas perdre encore lui
il fait ce mois parce que le seul nom
quand j'étais pas peur aux secours bien
sûr c'est le seul mot qui vous vient à
l'esprit au sco pour que je remercie
aussi la dame exactement vie j'avais
savina vitaly n'a qu'ils étaient filmés
et qui vous a sauvé peut-être une
agression encore plus violente même si
elle était extrêmement violente
vous n'aviez déjà vu dans ce restaurant
où il travaillait pas dedans j'ai vu
c'est partout à la fois fin juin contre
ce jour là non mais c'est important de
le dire parce que aujourd'hui il ya des
appels aux représailles
elle a entendu hier sur ce plateau quand
vous entendez qu'il ya des gens qui
veulent qu'ils aient des représailles
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de leur
dire donc l'avez dit vous voilà et c'est
la première chose que vous aviez vous la
violence c'est pas votre truc vous
connaissez pas vous pensiez pas du tout
qu'il allait être violent envers vous
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire
aux gens qui veulent faire des
représailles par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé qui est inadmissible bien entendu
donc parce que en vidant dans un pays de
droit donc liberté égalité fraternité
donc parce qu'il ya la loi on est haut
au dessus de la loi donc voilà ce que la
belge avait lancé je vais pas que je
vais pas de représailles on dit que moi
je n'aime pas ça du tout un chien donc
on est là dans la paix dans la joie et
de l'amour donc je vais là c'est ce
message que et aux couleurs gris noir
rouge bleu nation donc voilà essayer de
chercher la paix non à la violence et
puis une non aux racistes du coup vous
avez bien raison de dire ça se soit à
prion
a priori j'oublie re le patron du
restaurant le bras ce qu a été
auditionné au commissariat de cergy
pontoise il a été convoqué par rapport à
la fermeture administrative de son
restaurant à la suite des menaces de
mort qu'il a reçus il a transmis sa chez
le tout les caméras de surveillance les
policiers ont bien vu que la personne
n'est pas entré dans son restaurant avec
l'enseigné rouge mais dans un autre
restaurant avec une enseigne noir et
apparemment donc cette personne ne
travaillerait pas au bras ce coup voilà
d'après les premiers éléments de
l'enquète c'est extrêmement important
vous le savez pas ce que ça respire il a
sa vie qui a basculé à cause d'un voile
d'une personne qui ne travaille pas du
tout chez lui qui a commis un acte et
que c'est dégueulasse
voilà vous le dit les policiers lui ont
demandé donc si moore a travaillé pour
lui s'il le connaissait et cetera il a
bien sûr répondu que non dont les
policiers également ils vont analyser
des caméras de vidéosurveillance et
selon certaines sources
zoubir souhaiterait une confrontation
avec la dea l'agresseur pour prouver son
innocence et pour prouver que cette
personne ne travaille pas au brasco
juste dieu gros est-ce que vous allez
continuer à travailler aujourd'hui vous
dites je peux plus donc je me livre moi
c'est non je te vois qu'un incident
avait pas bougé pas toi parce que je
n'ai pas vu un jus parce que c'est parce
que j'ai une famille du rouge oui je
code gosse mais comment ils ont ils ont
dû être choqués de ce qui vous est
arrivé
i qu'est ce que vous en dites documents
pour le moins ils sont de 9 ans à deux
ans bien sûr est le petit 9 ans ou la
petite de 9 ans et elle a compris ce qui
s'était passé où vous avez essayé
d'épargner donc je vais pas plaindre
j'ai passé juste par l'armée fin de
l'ouverture
j'aimais ça de côté dans tes enfants ne
pas redescendre en bio grow en tout cas
je voulais vous dire ce soir que vous
avez eu un témoignage et des paroles qui
sont très importantes pour toutes les
personnes qui nous regardent ce soir et
votre message de paix j'espère qu'il va
être repris par tous je vous souhaite en
tout cas beaucoup de bonheur j'espère
que vous allez pouvoir reprendre une vie
normale et oublier cette cette agression
horribles dont vous avez été victime
et je vous remercie d'avoir été là ce
soir merci rue racine